- So you're from Denver.
I actually didn't remember
that you were from Colorado.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's awesome.
So, how often do you get back to Denver?
Do you ever get back?
- I get back probably seven
or eight times a year.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's good.
- I've found this place,
five-star service to stay at,
it's my parents' house
and it is incredible.
(all laughing)
I go back there and this-
So, childhood bedroom is
unchanged since June of '89
when I graduated from high school.
- [Kelly] What?
- Oh my, wow.
- It is a time capsule.
You open the door, you can
smell the Drakkar Noir.
It is-
(all laughing)
This was across, this has been
across from my bed since '86.
Every night, it's Arnold, "Go to sleep."
- Oh my God, wait in "Predator"
that was that crrrrr,
that was that sound that, yeah
- That was it.
And now we're friends and
every time I tell him,
"I, I had your poster on my bedroom wall,"
he's like, that's not even creepy a little
bit Aspen.
(audience laughs)
I wish I would've your
poster on my bedroom wall.
- [Kelly] That is an amazing impression.
- Oh it's, it's like my
mom, people will come
to the house and they
go, oh, it's, it's like
you have a 13 year old son.
I'm like, I do stand up
comedy and talk about ninjas.
You kind of do mom.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
That's amazing.
People would love that.
What kind of posters did y'all have?
- Hm, my whole wall above
my bed was Bon Jovi.
Bon Jovi and Sebastian Bach.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
I love that!
- The greatest front man of a
heavy metal band of all time.
- And some Axel Rose.
- [Kelly] I love Axel
Rose. What about ya'll?
- Jim Morrison was in silk above my bed.
- [Kelly] Love it.
What about you?
- I had Adam Ant, and some banjo players
which is so lame.
- [Kelly] I love that.
I love that.
- Steve Martin is nodding along right now.
- Yeah.
- I don't believe banjo
players have posters.
- Bon Jovi. His hair
was amazing in the 80s.
It is still.
Still. It is still.